nous nous retrouvons donc dans un
système qui est de plus en plus opaque
et illisible en octobre 2022 la Cour des
comptes soulignée que je cite la
sédimentation historique des recettes et
a fait le constat que notre système
était de plus en plus complexe et à bout
de souffle ce système opaque illisible
entrave l'action des collectivités
locales qui n'ont pas de visibilité sur
les réformes fiscales les décisions
d'attribution des dotations
d'investissement ou alors l'imposition
des normes de toute nature
l'éparpillement des mesures budgétaires
et fiscales concernant les collectivités
locales dans la loi de finances ne fait
qu'ajouter à la confusion qui s'est
installée dans les relations financières
entre l'État et nos collectivités ou les
tâches souvent à faire payer au
collectivités justement ce qu'il ne
souhaite plus assumer d'où notre
proposition qui réside dans deux points
d'une part la création d'une loi de
financement des collectivités
territoriales d'autre part une
compensation dynamique dans le temps des
transferts opérés s'agissant de la loi
de financement des collectivités locales
je rappelle que c'est quelque chose qui
est historiquement
ancré avec le rapport d'Olivier Guichard
de 1976 repris régulièrement notamment
dans le rapport lombaire Malvy
les objectifs de cette loi de
financement sont simples
un cadre de référence unique pour le
Parlement un outil de transparence pour
une meilleure information des élus
locaux une lisibilité et une visibilité
pour les collectivités territoriales à
même de conférer ce dont elles ont
besoin c'est-à-dire de la prévisibilité
une meilleure
lisibilité également des engagements
financiers de l'État et enfin une
clarification des responsabilités de
chacun